If I'm super honest, [music] what are
the three things in my business that
kind of gave me a stomach ache? And to
your point, one of them often is I'm not
having fun.
>> Yeah. Like [laughter]
>> we have low morale.
>> Yeah.
>> We feel bad and we want to talk about it
and that's totally cool. Like on the
agenda,
>> let's do it. Like let's talk through it.
>> All right. Welcome to Dalton Plus
Michael. Today, I think we're going to
ask a question that I think as office
hourgivers, we've learned to ask
ourselves quite a bit. When a founder
comes in to talk to us, I think the
question we sometimes ask ourselves is
exactly what advice does this person
want?
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> What are we going to be doing today?
>> I'll just I'll just ask them. [laughter]
>> I'll be like, what kind of office hours
is this? What advice do you want to hear
from me? Let me start off with like a
really common example I hear,
>> which is
>> they'll be like, "Oh, we got an offer to
get acquired."
>> Yes.
>> What do you think we should do? And I
will say, "Look, let's be real.
>> Is what's going on here? You've already
decided that you're going to do it." Y
>> and that you just want to tell me about
it in a roundabout way and you want me
to be excited for you.
>> Yes.
>> Or do you not want to do it and you just
need the pep talk that it's a good idea
to not take it?
>> Exactly. So, I've just learned to ask
that at the front of the office hours.
>> And it's it's actually helpful for both
parties to know which way they want to
take it, right? It's funny because we
have this concept in YC called shopping
for advice, right? And we often say some
version of if you already know what you
want to do, you know, step one isn't go
talk to a bunch of adviserss and find
one who agrees with you, [laughter] like
just like do the thing. Like do the
thing. Where I get in trouble as an
advice giver is when the topic is meta
advice and I don't realize it. Like when
the topic is like I want a cheer up and
I think the founder actually wants to
talk about practical things to do in
their startup, you know, and I'm sitting
here trying to get details and they're
really trying to tell me I'm thinking
about shutting it down,
>> right? [laughter]
In which case, like the design of the
front page is not really, [laughter] you
know, it's like
>> no. And then what they'll do is they'll
bring it up in the final two minutes.
They'll be like, "Oh, by the way, three
of the four founders are leaving and you
know, don't you love those where they
just like slip it in at the very end?"
>> What would you do if you only had three
months of runway? [laughter] Like as a
founder, I think you can just be
upfront, right? Like the best teams have
agendas, but not just kind of like what
do I think the adviser wants to talk
about? like actually what's our purpose
here? The other thing that comes up a
lot is as an advice giver I'm always
telling myself I just don't know enough
facts on the ground or actually said
more broadly I want to draw a line
around stuff where I'm not going to give
good answers and I want to have like a
really solid borders like tell me what
my customer wants like I don't know
right or like summarize the entire
history of my industry for the past 25
years [laughter]
or can you make a list of every investor
who likes investing in company
>> [laughter]
>> So, I almost just want to like create
like a border and be like, "Hey, don't
ask me."
>> In this area [laughter]
where on the flip side, I'd love your
thoughts on this. I find that what I'm
really good on is trying to probe the
founder on where should they be focused.
And we've talked about this a little bit
before about hedging, but like often
times I kind of find myself asking
questions over and over again like
what's the best opportunity? What's the
biggest problem? Wh what's on your to-do
list and what's the order?
>> Yeah.
>> How do you think about that?
>> One of the meta pieces of advice that we
always give is to learn how to work with
lawyers. And I'm going through this a
lot. We're leading rounds into companies
and so I'm dealing with a lot of lawyers
right now, man. That's like 20% of my
calendar is lawyers.
>> Okay.
>> So, here's how we advise founders out
there to to deal with lawyers. You
ready, folks?
>> Tell the lawyer what you want and give
them constraints.
>> Yes.
>> And then ask for legal advice.
>> Yes. Yes. [laughter]
And and the reason is if you don't do
that, they can go way out of scope and
often will go like red line a lot of
documents and come up with all these
extraneous points. You're basically the
boss of the lawyer. Like they're service
providers. But Dalton, that takes work.
Like they're the expert. They've done
this 100 times. I just want them to do
it. I just want them to tell me the
answer. Isn't that why I pay them? Same
with an adviser, right? Just tell me
what to do, right? Isn't that
>> Isn't that your job, adviser? [laughter]
I think that these folks are used to
having clients that give them advice.
And so what happens with startup
founders are inexperienced is they never
learned this lesson. Like this is one of
those lessons you learn in practice,
which is you kind of want to rein in.
You want to ring fence. Here's the type
of legal advice I'm looking for. Make
sure I don't go to jail.
>> Make sure like something really bad
isn't happening. Otherwise, I want to
get this deal done. Sign the deal.
>> How would you apply those same thinkings
to when someone is talking to their
angel investor or their adviser or their
friend doing startups and trying to get
advice? I think you want to
explain what kind of advice you're
looking for. Like what is your goal of
the advice session?
>> Yeah.
>> Like, hey, do you think right now is a
good time to fund raise? Okay, that's
like a that's a good agenda to ask an
investor. Yes.
>> But if it's completely open-ended, you
you tend to get extremely random advice.
>> Yeah. Rand and random in this context is
probably not what you're looking for.
Now, okay, I'm going to play devil's
advocate. I've been accused of this. I
assume you've been accused of this
before where a founder comes in and
their agenda is missing the core issue.
It's like, "Hey, we've been shot eight
places. There's a hole in our order. Can
we talk about the sprained ankle?"
>> Yeah.
>> And there's a whole sprained ankle
agenda.
>> When do you feel like you need to be
like, "Hey, why are we even talking
about this?" Like, "Hey, can let's talk
about the important thing, not the
unimportant." think it's when you can
sense that someone is dancing around
the core topic. And again, you could be
I could be wrong, but sometimes I can
kind of read between the lines. Yeah.
>> When it's like filler content.
>> Filler content.
>> They they just don't want to go for the
main uh topic. A founder that I worked
with a few uh years ago wrote a LinkedIn
post. It was pretty funny. It's one of
those, you know, where they anonymize
what partner told them the advice.
Definitely me
>> and they're like, "Our first office
hours at YC, we had one agenda item,
which is should we rename our company to
a better.com?" And the partner told us
Yeah. [laughter] the part our YC partner
told us to not waste our his time like
this ever again and to come back
[laughter]
>> when he had a real problem. And then and
then in the wrestling temple, he's like,
"This was the best advice we ever got.
You know, this is so awesome." And you
know, I wanted to be like just at me
next time. You know,
>> getting good advice requires some prep.
Sometimes people are elevated into
these, you know, oracle style figures.
And it's kind of like,
you know, even if you talk to who's an
oracle, Peter Teal is an or like you
talk to Peter Teal, he does nothing
about your business. You're not raising
any agenda. You're completely focused.
And it's just like tell me things that
could help my startup.
Maybe not setting things up for success.
The other bit on this that I think is a
little bit tricky is how often you want
to make sure you're getting the right
expertise out of the person you're
talking to. Like how would you advise
founders to understand
what the person they're talking to is
actually expert in and what they're not
expert in?
>> It's a great question because I've seen
this backfire. [laughter]
And so when I was a new YC partner,
>> yeah,
>> it was like, "Okay, Dalton, you know a
lot about consumer and the music
industry,
>> so let me ask you questions about the
entertainment industry."
>> And run. [laughter]
>> Okay. A,
>> that's a really small set of expertise
that's not useful. Yes.
>> B, it was stuff I never wanted to talk
about. And C, I missed the point where I
actually think the stuff that I was best
suited to talk about was things like
hiring and firing and growth. We had a
lot of growth. So did you. You were
growth. We were both growth experts when
we were, you know, early in our career
as startup adviserss. Fundraising. I
knew a lot about um actually a lot of
developer tools. So how is this
something how would a founder know that
about you know you're the you're the
music guy, right? Like how would the
founder actually get a real dossier?
>> That's a great question. I think you
want to realize that just looking at the
superficial parts of someone's bio may
miss the points. And I think you would
have known that I was someone that
wanted to talk about developer tools and
infrastructure a lot and was really
interested in it because you would have
saw that I was a that I was a programmer
and that I was really into open source.
I think you would have been able to
figure that out even when I was a new
partner. And then now you could look at
my portfolio and if you were to look at
my portfolio and be like, "Wow, Dalton
has funded a lot of open source
companies."
>> Yeah,
>> he probably has a lot of opinions about
that.
>> Yeah,
>> that would be a good way to do it. I
definitely found founders being much
more interested in my
operating past than my investing past.
You know, you and I have funded so many
companies in so many industries that
people wouldn't even expect. I mean,
like I don't know, like
>> developing country lending, you know,
we're [laughter] on that.
>> Yeah. And and sometimes I think what
founders are really trying to do is
figure out everyone else who I have
funded in their general category and
kind of try to get out of me what I've
learned. And I wish sometimes they had
just asked that straight, [laughter]
you know, like and if the answer is I
have never funded anyone in your
category, let's get that out like right
away.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, often times I get founders ask
me some version of like, oh, how have
you seen other companies in our category
die? And I'm like that is a really good
question. like I can I can go through
that.
>> So, how would you wrap this up, right?
I'm a founder. What would you put in my
mind before going and talking to an
investor or any type of adviser?
>> I think it's almost like how you would
view any meeting, which is what is my
goal of this meeting? And so, before you
even have it,
>> yes.
>> What would you view success as? Is it
getting answers to these questions? Is
it talking through your feelings so you
feel better? Again, a lot of office
hours
>> really are talking Yeah. And that's
okay. But if if if what the founder
wants to do is they're like, "Hey,
honestly, I've just been having a really
hard time the past few months." Yeah.
>> I just want to like talk things through.
I'm like, "Great. Happy to provide that
service." Um, and so I think, yeah,
having a personal goal, yes, for what
the outcome is from meeting with someone
I think is a good idea. I think the only
thing I would add is like what are the
top three real problems in my business?
Not pop problems or fake problems or
things I read about Twitter, but like if
I'm super honest, what are the three
things in my business that kind of gave
me a stomach ache? And to your point,
one of them often is I'm not having fun.
>> Yeah. Like [laughter] we're
>> we have low morale.
>> Yeah.
>> We feel bad and we want to talk about
it. And again, that's totally cool. Like
on the agenda,
>> let's do it. Like let's talk through it.
>> I think maybe the the only last thing I
will say is in this setting, honesty is
so important. Man, the quality of what
you give us is is the only factor in the
quality of what we give you back. Well,
again, it goes back to prompting, which
is if you type in a really generic, lame
prompt, you're probably going to need a
generic lane answer. But if you spend
the time to craft like a really good
prompt with a lot of unique
>> aspects to it, you'll get really
interesting answers.
>> Yes.
>> Well, and often time when you're super
honest about something that you think is
really bad, like our reaction is like,
"Oh, no. You see that? Like, you think
that's bad?" But when you hide that, you
might leave that meeting being like,
"Oh, we're totally screwed." and not
need it. Now you know what type of
advice to ask for. Cheers. Thanks.